[Music]
hi and welcome to serverless migration
station a serverless expedition
mini-series dedicated to helping
developers modernize their apps to using
the latest features on our serverless
compute platforms today martin and i are
hopping back on porter the train to
continue our journey to migrating to
cloud memory store that's great wes last
time in module 12 we added app engine
memcache to our sample ndb flask app
what are we doing today
glad you asked martin today we pick up
from where module 12 leaves off
migrating that sample app from app
engine adb to cloud ndb and app engine
memcache to cloud memory store and i
think i've asked this before wes but
isn't that two migrations that's right
martin while we're doing both migrations
we're only focusing on memcached memory
store because ndb to cloud adb's
migration was already covered in module
two moving from legacy app engine bundle
services like any b and memcache to
standalone services like cloud nab in
cloud memory store makes your apps more
portable in case you ever need to move
your app off of app engine
that does make sense
portable apps means more options for me
anything else another reason is if your
caching needs change while a simple
memcache service works for you today
your needs may require more advanced
features redis is a popular backend
storage service where besides caching it
can also serve as your array or hash in
the cloud instead of in memory thus
shareable with other apps or services
okay i'm sold how should i get ready for
this migration well you need a working
module 12 app either in python two or
three so you have three options here
grab yours from when you did module 12
code lab
do the module to colab now
or
clone the repo or download the zip file
and pick one of the module 12 folders to
start sounds good wes i was able to find
my module 12 code here and i'm ready to
tackle it now great
now let's talk about what we're doing
as you know this app caches the most
recent visits for the same visitor while
we're keeping that functionality but
moving it to caching with cloud memory
store since it's a standalone product
and not serverless we have to do a bit
more setup meaning that it's not just
about updating the code
since there are extra steps here i'd
like to follow along uh while you are
explaining it can you link me to the
codelab yep the link to the codelab is
here and down below so you can take it
step by step and pause the video if
needed okay let's go to the computer now
okay we'll start with the code first
then talk about setting up a memory
store instance plus a vpc connector if
you have a lib folder delete it python 2
users need to explicitly bundle third
party libraries and that's what the lib
folder is for so run this pip install
command to create or recreate it this is
done for python 3 users during the build
so you don't have to worry about it
everyone then should run gcloud app
deploy and confirm the deploy app caches
the most recent visits you can tell its
cache when the first request takes a
little bit of time but subsequent page
reloads are much quicker because they're
coming from the cache rather than from
datastore
now let's update the config files
starting with adding a few more
third-party packages to requirements.txt
module 12 only needed flask but now we
need to add google cloud ndb
one of the benefits for using cloud
memory store for redis is that you only
need the standard redis python client so
let's add that too use of cloud
libraries like cloud ndb in python 2
requires a pair of built-in libraries
we'll add to app.yaml in a moment and
anytime built-in libraries are used app
engine config needs to point your app to
them so we're also adding these same
lines to module two
python three users don't have to lift a
finger as app engine config isn't even
used in python 3.
now it's time to add two or three new
sections to the module 12 app.yaml
python2 users need to add a library
section specifying gprpcio and setup
tools which are the libraries required
to use cloud libraries corresponding to
the updates we just made to app engine
config
all other changes apply to both python 2
and 3 starting with a pair of
environment variables for a cloud memory
store the private ip address and port
number of your instance and the last new
section is for the vpc connector your
app engine app needs to communicate with
your cloud memory store instance
required fields highlighted are the
project id region and vpc connector name
at this point none of the info for these
two sections is available yet so leave
them as placeholders for now that's it
for config let's move to main.py to read
environment variables we need the os
module since redis can only cache
strings instead of python objects we
need to marshal the most recent visits
using pickle
wrapping up the import changes swap out
app engine ndb and memcache for cloud
nab and redis next you need an api
client so instantiate it right after
flask now we need to read the manage
redis host and port number from the
environment variables that will be set
in app.yaml with both pieces we can
instantiate redis next
that's it as far as setup goes now
moving into the real code module 2
covers how cloud adb is mostly
compatible with app engine ndb and that
it just needs with blocks around all of
the data store calls here being in both
store visit and fetch visits the
remaining updates merely swap out
memcache for redis
one additional change required is that
redis requires a string so we now pickle
the most recent visits list when setting
and unpickling it when getting
everything else stays the same
okay so those are all the changes to the
code before going back to the main
presentation and discuss how to set a
vpc and memory store we're not going to
walk through the full set of
instructions to help set up the memory
store instance and vpc connector because
that's covered in detail in the code lab
what i do want to show are the basic
steps you need to get memory store
working for your app
okay first things first what do you
really need two things a cloud memory
store instance and a serverless vpc
connector the most important thing is
that neither are free so be prepared i
will try to help you minimize cost
though beyond that it doesn't matter
which you create first because if you
create the memory store instance first
your app engine app can't reach it
without a serverless vpc connector and
if you make the vpc connector first
there's nothing on that vpc for your app
engine app to talk to so nope it doesn't
matter the most important thing is to
create both in the same region as your
app engine app we'll also give you a
link here and down below to the docs
page representing the steps we're going
to follow now
i'm doing cloud memory store first so go
to the cloud memory store for redis page
in the cloud console enable it and add
billing if necessary then click on
create instance at the top
our sample app has minimal needs and
there are lots of settings so to keep
the cost down we recommend the lowest
service tier basic and a minimal one gig
capacity unlike the 16 you're presented
with no suggestions on which version of
register choose though although i
usually don't pick the newest one as
older versions typically use less
resources so perhaps redis version 5.
anyway once it's created note its ip
address and port number similar to
memory store our sample app only needs a
bare bones vpc service to do this go to
the serverless vpc page in the cloud
console like memory store enable that
service here and add billing if
necessary once you do that you'll be at
the dashboard from there click on create
connector at the top
you can't select less than two instances
but instead of the default of ten
maximum crank that down to three
also the default e2 micro instances cost
more than the f1 microtypes which give
only one vcpu access instead of two so
pick that
lastly you do need to specify an ipv4 28
cider block which gives you 16 addresses
to work with the cloud console suggests
10.8.0.0.28 so use that or the first
unused slash 28 block available in your
project
while using the cloud console gives you
a great user experience showing you all
of your available options i'm really a
command line guy and already know what i
want so instead of fiddling with the ui
i can create both the memory store
instance and the vpc connector with
these two gcloud commands assuming that
my app engine app is in the us central
or central one region naming them demo
ms and demo vpc respectively and i've
chosen the minimal settings described
earlier you can run both at the same
time because they both take a couple of
minutes each
after completion i can run this other
pair of commands to confirm that both
demo ms and demo vpc are online
whether through the cloud console or
using the gcloud command copy the host
and port number of your memory store
instance into app.yaml and then grab the
vpc connector name and add that to its
entry in app.yaml along with your
project name in region once those
resources have been created your app
should have a caching service available
to it so let's deploy
python 2 users should redo their lib
folder and everyone can then run gcloud
app deploy once it's live you should
have an identically working app caching
the most recent visits for the same
visitor congrats
before going back to the main
presentation a few words about upgrading
to python 3. this app is already python
2 3 compatible so there are no changes
at all to main.py
neither app engine config.py nor the lib
folder are used in python 3 so delete
them
the only file requiring an update is
app.yaml change your runtime to the
latest python3 release and remove the
thread safe and api version directives
as neither are used in python 3 either
our sample app doesn't have static files
so delete the entire handler section
there are no longer built-in third-party
library so delete the entire library
section what's left the run time your
memory store instance information and
the vpc connector information now your
app is ported to python 3. again there
is no pip install so just g cloud app
deploy and that's it for module 13. so
let's wrap up
cool thanks for showing us that wes i
like how similar redis and memcache are
is there a guide to help me get a better
grasp of migrating app engine memcache
to cloud memory store oh definitely the
first link goes to a specific migration
guide for moving from app engine
memcache to cloud memory store
and while you're at it can you also
point me to the docs for the original
app engine memcache as well as the cloud
memory store for redis yep and both of
those are also linked down below great i
found this memcache migration very
useful are there any others i should
consider
sure plenty martin we also moved from
app engine ndb to cloud ndb to get more
details on that migration check out the
module 2 code lab and video another
migration is moving from map engine push
tasks to cloud tasks that's covered in
modules 789
from moving from app engine blob store
to google cloud storage see modules 15
and 16.
if your app engine app is made up of one
or two functions consider migrating it
to cloud functions and for that see
module 11.
finally if containerization is part of
your software development workflow
consider moving your app engine app to
cloud run see module 4 if you're
familiar with docker and module 5 if you
don't do containers or docker files wow
so many choices
thanks for helping app engine developers
modernize their apps wes
yep and thanks martin for coming along
the ride on our little friend porter for
each of these journeys and we look
forward to having you join us at another
migration station or on another
serverless expedition soon happy travels
[Music]
you